transition terminée depuis quatre ans
vous êtes artiste pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne vous connaissent
pas vous avez décidé
voilà de changer de vie pour fait on va
dire d'identité exactement de vie des
identités ya quatre ans il ya quatre ans
j'ai terminé weeds excusez moi ni
ma mère avait refait sa vie avec un
compagnon et elle l'a retrouvé mort dans
la douche voilà et ça a été le déclic et
je me suis dit la vie est trop courte
c'est ça il faut bien que je la fasse
comme j'ai envie de faire ouais sinon je
me tire une balle dit voilà moi je me
suis pas bien sûr m'a sauvé la noue
sentais pas bien comme vous étiez oui
voilà et quand cette nuit ça y est
maintenant jeux ak quel âge
déjà cette semaine donc je peux vous
demander votre âge encore vous avez 25
ans aujourd'hui vous en avez quoi 22,32
adacore 32 commente-t-on ça vous a pris
c'est un prix trois ans et deux mois
entre le premier rendez vous avec loppsi
jusqu'à la vaginoplastie d'accord vous
c'est quoi comme le métier moi je
travaillais dans un fast-food d'accord
suite en sortant du lycée après je suis
parti dans le spectacle parce que pour
moi c'était la seule manière de gagner
ma vie en étant enfin c'est ça alors
avant vous étiez vous appeliez comment
vous êtes là bas savent je répondrai pas
gérer c'est la question qui se pose pas
d'accord c'est ce même modèle n'a pas
d'avis
je pose des questions comme ça
c'est
une nouvelle vie à ces nouvelles vies
c'est une renaissance comme on dit je
repars à zéro le livret de famille a été
changé mais pas mais aussi ça a pris six
mois les papiers personnellement est ce
que vous êtes heureuse à mais
complètement là ça y est je serai pas là
pour en parler avec vous sentez bien
ouais et votre entourage comme il l'a
pris par mon père l'a très mal pris ma
soeur ça a été un peu
difficile aussi maintenant ça se passe
super bien ma mère par contre ma
compagne et du premier rendez vous de
ces au dernier c'est votre mère qui a
décroché le déclic et une robe ouais
j'ai été la grèce était vachement plus
proche de ma mère que de mon père donc
elle m'a accompagné à tous mes
rendez-vous à la était là et maintenant
en plus je fais un bisou à les malades
donc maintenant c'est moi qui la
soutient alors maintenant donc la
prochaine étape si vous vous présentiez
au concours miss france je ne peux pas
alors je ne peux pas parce que je n'ai
plus l'âge n'est pas le style mais je me
suis inscrite à un autre concours à nice
esthétique france d'accord est-ce que
alexia laroche-joubert la présidente de
la société miss france a fait une
annonce ce matin donnant l'impression
que ça a toujours été le cas avec dit
que voilà
exemple le sera avec nous après
d'ailleurs elle est pour voilà ce
concours qu'au cours évoluent regarde
toujours dit mais ça si vous lisez bien
règlement on demande à ce que l'identité
civile soit féminin mais donc ya pas de
problème s'il ya des des transsexuels
mais des transsexuels pourront consommer
les mêmes aliments dits d une carte d
identité féminine il ya aucun problème
mais vous allez je vais demander y avait
aucun souci
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais à ce pauvre moi
je suis pour complètement mais ce qui
serait bien aussi c'est d'enlever le mot
transsexuels en permanence bah quoi je
veux dire j'ai fini mon parcours je suis
une femme donc point voilà donc voilà
alors qu'est pour qui est contre ici à
laquelle on ajoute qu'aujourd'hui
influenceurs vous cette prise de
position ne vous plaît pas du plus fort
non elle me plaît pas parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est une énième
pénétration delà de la roque culture
dans des
dans la culture française et en plus là
alexia laroche joubert quand elle dit
que la femme enfin que la personne fait
sa transition pour devenir une femme
elle fait appel à la chirurgie
esthétique
non
c'est un travail si on enlève des
testostérones pas avoir des débats dans
y'a pas de chirurgie esthétique
réparatrice intentions mais pas
esthétique est donc d'accord mais tu vas
t'il que moi je trouve que le corps de
la femme de l'auteur de la personne est
modifié et donc et par conséquent elle
ne peut pas concourir à miss france et
puis je pense que miss france pour
beaucoup de gens pour beaucoup de
français eh bien ces décès des femmes et
excusez moi et pour beaucoup de physique
sexuelle pour beaucoup de français avait
une compagne mais si tout de suite je me
mets tout nu à côté d'elle les choses
seront à la même place exactement pareil
mais moi aussi d'ailleurs
mais c'est à dire que six mois comme moi
je mets une jauge est un peu caricatural
mais si moi demain je mets une perruque
je peut concourir à miss france
alors c'est ça le problème c'est que les
gens ils font un amalgame entre le
travesti la transe et c'est aussi des
rallyes c'est comme une femme
oui
quoi devant vous j'ai un nom je suis pas
content agi mais non mais c'est pas la
question être à mon sujet mais pas de
jugement j'essaie d'avoir une lecture
globale j'ai l'impression que pour
beaucoup de gens est bon pour moi y
compris les femmes trans excusez moi
c'est peut-être mon ressenti mais pour
moi les femmes trans ne sont pas tout à
fait des femmes vous dit que vous ne
fréquentez pas sans savoir
maintenant peut-être oui non mais
peut-être et peut-être que je suis fait
du rappel toi de ta dernière soirée
non mais c'est un peu con et j'ai
l'impression de que c'est du bon sens
mais bien pour beaucoup de gens le lait
les femmes ou les hommes trans ne sont
pas tout à fait des femmes je comprends
que pour beaucoup de gens ça choque